Muito obrigada por este convite
e muito boa tarde a todos.
Eu sou artista plástica,
pinto desde que me lembro
e escrevo histórias
que parecem para crianças,
mas que também são para adultos.
Aquilo que eu tento fazer é pôr as artes
ao serviço dos outros.
Eu sou voluntária de cabeceira
em hospitais pediátricos
onde visito e acompanho crianças
internadas e em grande sofrimento.
Também acompanho adultos
mas, acima de tudo,
dedico-me a crianças
consideradas diferentes.
Falo de crianças institucionalizadas,
retiradas às suas famílias,
mas também de crianças com autismo,
trissomia 21, entre outros.
Foi exatamente por este motive
que fiz uma pós-graduação
em desenvolvimento pelas artes precisas,
do Instituto Superior de Psicologia Aplicada
para me especializar e para me tornar
mais eficiente no meu voluntariado.
As minhas histórias
falam de príncipes e princesas
mas não têm nada a ver
com os príncipes e as princesas
que me contaram na minha infância.
Nessa altura, o que é que acontecia?
A princesa casava com o príncipe
e vivia feliz para sempre.
Acontece que a realidade
ultrapassa sempre a ficção
e a minha experiência tem mostrado
que ninguém vive feliz para sempre
e que os contos de fadas
não têm nada a ver com a realidade,
muito pelo contrário.
Nos meus livros, os príncipes as princesas
são inspirados em crianças reais
em crianças com quem me tenho cruzado
em situações de grande fragilidade.
e, para mim, elas são
infinitamente mais bonitas
do que qualquer príncipe
ou qualquer princesa dos contos de fadas.
Eu escrevo sobre crianças
consideradas diferentes,
crianças que são muitas vezes julgadas,
discriminadas e rotuladas pela sociedade.
Eu escrevo sobre elas e para elas.
Por isso, hoje gostava muito de vos contar
três histórias de três crianças
que marcaram a minha vida.
Três histórias muito simples
que me mostraram a complexidade da vida,
que me fizeram também a mim
mudar o meu rumo, as minhas escolhas,
e hoje, em vez de estar a expor
numa galeria lá fora,
optei antes por estar nos hospitais
à cabeceira destas crianças
e a acompanhá-las.
A primeira história
que eu vos vou contar é sobre a Alice.
Eu conheci a Alice enquanto
fui voluntária numa instituição.
A Alice estava institucionalizada,
com os seus dois irmãos pequeninos.
Todos estavam completamente
sozinhos e abandonados
porque a mãe não tinha condições
para cuidar deles.
Um dia, enquanto pintava
e conversava com a Alice
desenhávamos sonhos e pesadelos,
alegrias e tristezas,
a Alice revelou-me que tinha
muita dificuldade em adormecer.
que tinha muitos pesadelos.
Que, quando começava a fechar os olhos,
via imediatamente o padrasto a bater
com muita agressividade na sua mãe.
Os olhos dela continuavam
a encher-se de lágrimas
e dizia que se não fosse este
o pesadelo que a inquietava
era o outro, em que ela via
todos os seus colegas
a chamarem-na de burra.
Quando ela me contava estas histórias
eu ficava sem saber o que haveria de fazer
com uma enorme tristeza,
como devem calcular, e a pensar:
"Esta criança não tem nada de burra,
muito pelo contrário".
Eu penso que aquilo que aconteceu à Alice,
foi que a vida lhe pregou uma partida
e desconcentrou-a da própria vida,
porque existem crianças que,
infelizmente, nunca são crianças.
Aquilo que eu aprendi com a Alice foi
que nós nunca devemos julgar
as pessoas sem as conhecermos,
porque normalmente
o maior tesouro das pessoas
está escondido no seu interior.
Estas pessoas que passam
por grandes sofrimentos
muitas vezes colocam capas sobre capas
e depois nós não conseguimos
conhecê-las na realidade.
Então o que é que fazemos?
"É burra", "é tonta", e na realidade
não é nada disso que acontece,
até são pessoas muito interessantes,
pessoas profundas,
pessoas que têm um mundo inteiro
para nos mostrar.
Agradeço muito à Alice por me ter dado
esta pista tão valiosa para a minha vida.
A segunda história que eu vos vou contar
é uma história muito especial para mim
porque é uma história em que vos vou falar
sobre uma criança
que morreu aos sete anos,
que se chamava Maria
e que foi minha afilhada.
Apesar de não sermos família,
fiquei ligada aos seus pais
por circunstâncias adversas
que atravessavam
na altura em que nos conhecemos.
Conheci a Maria através dum amigo surfista
porque o pai da Maria
arranjava pranchas de "surf"
Lembro-me perfeitamente
do dia em que a conheci,
no dia em que cheguei a casa deles.
Era uma família que vivia,
e vive ainda, com muitas dificuldades
Lembro-me de chegar e ficar
imediatamente apaixonada
por aquela criança.
Como já perceberam,
as crianças fascinam-me
e aquela, naquele dia em especial,
foi amor à primeira vista.
Quando eu cheguei,
olhei para aquela criança
que tinha feito um tratamento
de quimioterapia no dia anterior
e fiquei impressionada com ela,
com a sua fragilidade.
Estava sem cabelo, devido
aos tratamentos que estava a fazer,
e, ao mesmo tempo,
fiquei fascinada com a sua força
porque ela andava atrás
dos irmão mais velhos com espadas,
a lutar às espadas com os irmãos
e eu pensava:
Esta miúda é incrível,
como é que ela ontem sai dum tratamento
tão doloroso como aquele
e hoje anda a lutar
às espadas com os irmãos.
A Maria era uma força da Natureza
Eu penso que ela era diferente
porque tinha uma capacidade invulgar
de aceitar a sua doença.
Mas a sua maior diferença,
eu penso que era no amor.
Ela amava de uma forma diferente.
Uma vez, quando a Maria,
ainda muito pequenina,
estava no IPO, chegou lá uma criança
que vinha da Guiné.
Quem a olhasse de perto
percebia imediatamente
que a vida não a tratara da melhor forma
Chamava-se Sussumané,
não tinha ninguém com ele,
e todo o carinho que esta criança recebia,
vinha apenas dos auxiliares
e das enfermeiras do hospital.
Ninguém se aproximava dele,
porque ele tinha o corpo coberto de chagas
e o pus e o sangue que delas saíam
tornavam-no perfeitamente impressionante.
Por isso, os pais também o evitavam
e não punham os seus filhos
a brincar com ele.
Mas a minha afilhada sentiu-se
imediatamente atraída por ele quando o viu.
Era ainda mais pequenina,
devia ter uns três ou quatro anos,
e agarrou imediatamente nele
para ir brincar.
Eu penso que ela se sentiu atraída
pelo seu sorriso, pela sua fragilidade
mas, acima de tudo,
conhecendo-a como a conheci,
acredito que ela se sentiu atraída
pela sua solidão.
Nós crescemos a querer
— eu por mim falo —
a querer, quando somos pequenos,
"Quero ser amiga da mais popular,
"porque é a que tem mais amigos",
os rapazes querem ser amigos
dos que jogam melhor futebol,
e vem esta criança,
com este tamanho e diz-me:
"Calma, eu quero que tu sejas amiga
do mais sozinho, do mais frágil".
De tal maneira que, sempre que
a minha afilhada estava sozinha no quarto,
ela nunca perdia a oportunidade
de pedir à sua mãe Susana
que fosse visitar o Sussumané.
Porque ela tinha a consciência
que aquela criança não tinha lá a mãe dele
para poder cuidar dele.
Eu agradeço muito à Maria
porque ela me ensinou
que devemos preocupar-nos com os outros,
ao ponto de nos esquecermos
de nós próprios.
Estava agora a olhar para a fotografia
da minha afilhada, isto é saudade
mas houve uma vez uma criança que disse:
"Saudade é o amor que fica",
por isso ainda bem que estou a sentir isto.
A terceira história que eu vos vou contar
é sobre o António
que foi uma criança que eu conheci
num dia em que fui visitar
a Maria ao hospital,
porque ela encontrava-se já
numa fase terminal.
Quando cheguei ao IPO,
naquela salinha de espera onde os pais
aguardam para entrar com os seus filhos,
estava uma mãe nova
com o seu filho ao colo.
Eu perguntei-lhe
como é que ele se chamava,
e ela disse-me: "António".
Em seguida, talvez porque nesse dia
eu também estava à procura
duma resposta para mim própria,
perguntei-lhe se tinha fé,
ao que ela me respondeu:
"Eu tinha, mas olhe
o que eu tenho ao colo".
Com certeza que existem alturas na vida
em que é preciso muita fé para ter fé.
Eu meti as mãos à cabeça a pensar:
"Eu não estou mesmo boa de todo,
o que é que eu lhe fui perguntar?"
Passado um bocado,
para tentar remediar a situação,
eu tinha uma frase no bolso,
que alguém me tinha oferecido
no dia anterior, que dizia:
"Foi quando tu mais precisaste de mim
que eu te peguei ao colo".
Fui ter com aquela mãe
e ofereci-lhe essa frase.
Ela continuou a ficar em silêncio
e eu voltei a meter as mãos à cabeça:
"O que é que eu fui fazer?"
Só que depois chamaram-na
para ela entrar lá para dentro com o filho
para fazer o tratamento.
Quando ela voltou e aquelas portas,
que tanta tristeza arrastam, se abriram,
ela fez-me o sorriso mais bonito
que alguém alguma vez já me fez.
Acreditem que eu às vezes
vejo revistas de moda e etc.,
e nem a Claudia Schiffer fez alguma vez
um sorriso mais bonito do que aquele.
Era um sorriso mais de anjo do que pessoa
e depois disse-me:
"Sabe, há muito tempo
que eu não tinha esperança,
mas hoje entrei ali dentro
cheia de confiança.
Passaram-se dois anos.
Entretanto, é detetado
um novo tumor na Maria,
a minha afilhada é internada
no 7.º piso do IPO, em isolamento.
Eu lembrei-me de perguntar pelo António.
Fui ter com uma enfermeira
e perguntei-lhe se sabia do António.
Ela disse-me que o António
também estava internado ali no 7.º piso
e que também estava em isolamento.
Fui a correr ter com a Maria.
Como sabia que ela era uma criança especial
certamente me iria dar
também uma pista especial.
e disse-lhe: "Maria, a madrinha
tem ali um amigo pequenino
"que está sozinho e que está doente.
"Tens alguma coisa
que lhe queiras oferecer
"ou alguma coisa que lhe queiras dizer?"
Ela tinha duas pulseiras,
uma azul e uma cor-de-rosa.
Claro que tirou a azul
— que era a cor de rapaz —
e que também tinha inscrita
uma frase de esperança.
E pediu-me para eu lha oferecer.
Eu fui a correr
até à outra ponta do corredor
— lembro-me como se fosse hoje —
bati à porta, fui ter com aquela mãe,
perguntei-lhe se se lembrava de mim.
No início, não se recordou
mas depois, quando eu lhe revivi
aquele momento
que tínhamos vivido dois anos antes,
ela abraçou-me, um abraço demorado,
daqueles que nos enchem a alma
de paz, de amor, de sentido,
e disse-me:
"Sabe, eu não sei como é que você
se chama, também não quero saber.
"É melhor nem saber,
porque é muito melhor assim.
"Obrigada por me trazer as frases
nos dias em que eu mais preciso".
Eu e aquela mãe partilhámos o essencial
sem nunca termos sabido
o nome uma da outra.
Eu acho que, se eu, que sou uma pessoa
com tantas imperfeições,
com tantas fragilidades,
tive a honra e o privilégio
de receber aquele abraço,
então certamente qualquer pessoa
no mundo também o terá.
Eu ainda visitei o António
mais duas ou três vezes
mas com muita tristeza minha, um dia
cheguei ao Instituto Português de Oncologia
e fui informada que o António
já não se encontrava entre nós.
Mas aprendi uma verdade essencial
para a minha vida.
Com ele e com a mãe dele,
aprendi que o amor,
mesmo sendo invisível, é muito visível.
Antoine de Saint-Exupéry já o dizia
por palavras mais sábias e mais poéticas.
Com todas estas crianças e sobre todas
aquelas de quem não contei nada,
aprendi que há uma casta de pessoas
que, para mim, são as "pessoas azuis".
É sobre elas que eu me debruço,
é sobre elas que eu escrevo,
é sobre elas que eu pinto.
E acho que, hoje em dia,
é também sobre elas que eu vivo
e que vivo com muito mais felicidade,
com muito mais sentido,
com muito mais amor.
As minhas histórias visam procurar
a busca interior de cada um de nós.
O que eu pretendo com elas
é que os adultos ensinem as crianças
a aceitar, a respeitar e a viver
com a diferença dos outros.
Porquê? Porque no amor
não existem diferenças.
O amor não é diferente.
As crianças diferentes
são sempre rotuladas e julgadas.
Se repararmos bem, também nós passamos
a vida a colocar rótulos uns aos outros,
sem tantas vezes permitimos ver o que é
que está para além desses mesmos rótulos.
O que eu defendo é que nós devemos
sempre fazer tudo para abrir o coração
em especial, às pessoas
que nos parecem mais diferentes.
Porquê? Porque eu acredito
que talvez assim o amor
que lhes foi roubado
ainda possa ser resgatado
porque eu acredito ainda
que uma criança que é amada
irá contribuir para um futuro
e para um mundo melhor.
Penso que cada um de nós
pode utilizar as suas competências
e as suas ferramentas,
pessoais e profissionais,
em prol das "pessoas azuis".
Na minha opinião, nós não devemos
usar a nossa educação
apenas em prol de nós próprios.
Devemos usá-la também em prol dos outros.
Um consultor, um médico, um engenheiro
eu penso que todas as pessoas podem
tentar tirar uma hora da sua semana,
um minuto do seu dia,
e tentar levar um sorriso.
Existem tantas crianças,
existem tantas famílias
que, com um abraço sentem-se
as pessoas mais felizes do mundo.
Foi o que aquela mãe
me disse que tinha sentido
pelo simples facto de eu ter ido
visitá-la uma segunda vez.
Descobri esta forma
de dar e receber, através da arte.
Mas eu penso que esta reciprocidade
pode ser descoberta
em qualquer área do conhecimento.
Basta estarmos atentos.
Estas crianças são, para mim,
uma enorme fonte de inspiração.
São elas que me permitem
e que me ajudam a preencher
o branco que falta nas minhas telas.
E depois aquilo
que eu faço é muito simples.
Eu devolvo-lhes apenas um pouco
do muito que elas me dão.
Muito obrigada.
(Aplausos)